Here are 10 Life-changing Lifehacks that you can try right now
This little trick will make it so you can
play games on your smart phone without having
to deal with strategically placed ads. Simply
try switching your phone over to airplane
mode. This will turn off the phones radio
function, and even make your battery last
longer, so you get more playing time, without
the incessant distractions.
If you've ever rented a car, you know the
feeling of pulling in to the gas station,
only to realize too late, that you forgot
to check which side the fill port was on.
Rather than being caught doing the walk of
shame, you can avoid the embarrassment altogether,
by glancing at the pump icon on your gas gauge.
There's a little arrow pointing to the side
you need to fill up on. So remember this little
trick the next time you borrow a car, and
you'll be a gas pump hero on the very first
try.
It's the season for grilling, and if you want
to switch things up at your next party, why
not skip the lighter fluid, and try starting
your charcoal with a handful of potato chips?
They make a surprisingly flammable tinder,
and will easily burn long enough to light
up a stack of coals. And this way, you won't
get that lighter fluid taste in your meat.
Ah, the kiwi fruit. It's so exotic and so
delicious, but how do you peel it without
hacking it up and leaving so much fruit on
the skins? The solution is so simple you won't
believe it. Try using a spoon. Just cut the
ends of the kiwi, then push your spoon inside,
making sure the back slides in along the peel.
Now carefully work the spoon around the inside
edge, until the entire fruit pops right out.
It really is that quick and easy, and hardly
anything gets left behind.
Uh oh. Somebody just lost their smart phone,
and will probably be in a panic once they
realize it. Before this happens to you, take
a picture of your email address, or some other
contact information written in big letters.
Go ahead and save it as your lock screen photo,
and now if your phone ever does get lost,
the first thing anyone will see, is exactly
how to get it back to you.
Every day we face a torturous moment of truth,
when we turn on the shower, and get blasted
by icy cold water. If it's not cold, then
it's unbearably hot. But you can easily fix
this daily challenge with a bottle of nail
polish or white-out. The next time you find
the sweet spot, mark the trim plate and the
handle with a couple of dabs that line up
with each other. Now you've got the power
to win this epic battle, by hitting the perfect
temperature on the very first try.
How Embarrassing. Your tie keeps getting twisted
out of place, and it's so frustrating to have
to keep checking and straightening it all
the time, isn't it? Let's rig up a permanent
fix with an old dress shirt, and a pair of
scissors. Carefully cut the front strip so
you end up with a piece just a bit longer
than the two button holes. Now then next
time you dress up, simply slip one of these
"tie savers" through the keeper loop on your
tie. Fasten it to the buttons on your shirt,
and now your tie will always be straight,
look great, and fall back into place even
when it gets knocked around in the wind.
The frustration that comes when wrapping
up leftovers, because the rolls keep pulling
up out of the boxes. Sometimes they seem more
trouble than they're worth, but luckily, there's
a quick and easy fix. Just get a knife and
cut a downward facing arrow on the ends of
the boxes, directly in the center. Now simply
push these tabs inward to secure the roll
in place, and keep it conveniently in the
box, every time you pull. By the way, some
boxes already have little push tabs built
right in. So start using them, and make
your life that much easier.
Do you wake up in the morning with a stiff
neck and a headache? It might be because your
pillow is cranking on your spine all night
long. But rather than spending loads of money
on specialty pillows, try lifting your head
a bit and tucking the edge of your pillow,
under your neck. Lay back down, with the corners
over top of your shoulders, and you've just
made an ergonomic support for your neck and
head. This will help straighten out your spine,
and instantly make any pillow you're using,
feel like it should have cost a lot more.
Plastic grocery bags. They're worth hanging
on to, but they can quickly take over your
drawer space. To eliminate the clutter, simply
flatten them out, and fold the bags in half
lengthwise. Now lay them in a straight line,
with the handles overlapping the bottoms of
the previous bags, then roll the whole thing
up. You can add as many bags as you want,
and in a couple of minutes, you'll have an
instant bag dispenser that will take up very
little space. Now if you put this in some
kind of container, it will dispense one bag
at a time, whenever you need it.
Well there are 10 life changing life-hacks
that you can try right now. If you liked these
projects, perhaps you'll like some
of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com